la précarité c'est aussi niveau scolaire
ça va être mis dans une voix qu'on
n'apprécie pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma mère également beaucoup et
travaillent quatre heures par jour
tout ça pour 100 euros par mois c'est
chou
[Musique]
c'est quand tu n'as pas de maison quand
tu n'arrives pas vraiment atteindre la
fin du mois quand tu peux pas avoir ce
que tu veux quand tu veux que tu te ne
peux pas te nourrir comme tu as envie
d'habiller comme tu as envie aller là où
tu envie faire des activités que tu veux
aller en vacances
pour moi c'est ça beaucoup de gens
n'importe quel prix car c'est peut-être
que ouais c'est vivre dans un f1 et tout
ça mais précaire c'est beaucoup de
choses
c'est la précarité sociale c'est pas
avoir peut-être beaucoup d'amis parce
que ben moi j'ai toujours dit ben
l'argent c'est le pouvoir et d'argent là
des copains mais qu'on a rien dans les
poches
on appuie trop d'amis
[Musique]
josé pas ramener des années à des amis à
moi depuis j'avais honte sur ça un peu
parce que dans un hôtel tu peux pas
ramené la honte que regard des gens si
tu te dispute avec une amie à toi aval
raconte à tout le monde oui elle habite
dans un hôtel
c'est ça le pas de maison mais les
pauvres
elle mange pas donc oui j'avais un peu
honte mais donc j'en parlais pas j'avais
honte mais j'en parlais pas donc ça va
essayer de cacher la situation actualisé
à des copains à l'école
oui où je cachais oui parce que mes amis
à cet âge on est bête peut pas qu'on ait
une mauvaise image de moi et de ma mère
parce que c'est pas de la faute de ma
mère mais eux ils se connaissent pas
c'est très difficile il ya beaucoup de
culpabilité parce que c'est pas maison
fonds qui sont responsables de cette
situation
c'est plutôt moi et je culpabiliserai
toute ma vie parce que c'est quelque
chose qui se rattrape pas c'est des
années d'enfance perdu qu'ils se
rattraperont jamais ma mère elle est un
peu un peu déçu de pas nous offrir ce
qu'elle a envie ce qu'on veut mais moi
je n'en veux pas c'est pas de sa faute
en est pour moi j'ai ce que je veux donc
ça va j'ai ce que je veut peut-être pas
à l'heure mais tout en gelée ne vaut
tard que jamais j'ai mes deux parents
qui ont travaillé pendant pas mal
d'années quand même j'aime en mer ben
côté d'eux venu d'algérie elle
travailler dans des usines elle a fait
le ménage tout ça et j'ai mon père a
qu'ils soient aveugles à travailler on
va dire à peu près 15 ans à l'usiné
après accumulé pas mal de petits boulots
la situation financière pour ma part
c'est quelque chose d'un peu tabou on
n'en parle pas beaucoup
même si bien des fois ça va pas des fois
c'est plus difficile tout ça tough ses
murs relations sociales mais je pense ça
m'a forgé avec le temps c'était dur et
tout mais je pense causés dans la galère
ça vous fait savoir qui sont les gens
bien qui sont des gens veulent savoir ce
truc qui comptait ce que je veux c'est
avoir de l'argent et de rendre heureux
mais mes proches depuis l'âge de 9 ans
j'ai envie d'être avocate et je pense
que j'y arriverai du faut se donner les
moyens quand on veut on peut
et chaque jour est une victoire en
[Musique]